welcome everyone this is the first
screencast in our series on natural
language inference or nli this is one of
my favorite problems what i'd like to do
is give you a sense for how the task is
formulated and then situate the task
within the broader landscape of ideas
for nlu
as usual we have a bunch of materials
that would allow you to get hands-on
with this problem the core module is
nli.pi and then there are two notebooks
the first introduces the three data sets
that we'll be exploring in detail snli
multi-nli and adversarial nli
and the second notebook offers a bunch
of different modeling approaches
it really covers core approaches that
people have taken to nli in the past and
i hope it points to some avenues for
modifying those architectures possibly
in the service of developing an original
system for a final project
there's also an associated homework and
bake off i emphasize that this is not
required for us this quarter i'm
mentioning it because i think the
problem is an interesting one it's a
word entailment task which is an
interesting small scale problem that i
believe could be used to stress test an
nli system in interesting ways
the core readings cover the three data
sets that will be in focus for us and
then the final reading listed here was i
think the paper that introduced
attention mechanisms into the study of
nli and that had an impact that went
well beyond this task
and then for additional readings i'm
kind of suggesting a range of things
some of these readings cover core
fundamentals for deep learning that i
think will be useful in the context of
studying nli
some of them help you with kind of a
foundational understanding of the nli
task and how you might think about it
and then some of them are meant to kind
of push us to stress test our system
think adversarially and maybe find
artifacts in our data sets and those are
going to be themes of later screencasts
in this series
to begin getting a sense for how the
task is formulated let's start with some
simple examples here
so in nli we have as our inputs a
premise sentence and a hypothesis
sentence and the task is a
classification one so in this simple
example here the premise sentence is a
turtle dance the hypothesis sentence is
a turtle moved both of those are system
inputs and our task is to assign one of
three labels in this case the correct
label would be in tails
the second example looks simple but it
actually begins to suggest how the task
is actually formulated we have as our
premise turtle and as our hypothesis
linguist and what we would like to do in
the context of nli is assign that the
contradicts label now you might pause
there and think it's not a logical fact
that turtles can't be linguists so
surely contradiction is too strong but
it is a common sense fact a kind of
natural inference about the world we
live in that no turtles are linguists
and it's for that reason that we would
choose the contradicts label and that
begins to key into the fact that
fundamentally nli is not a logical
reasoning task but a more general common
sense reasoning task
every reptile danced is neutral with
respect to a turtle eight which is just
to say that these two sentences can be
true or false independently of each
other
and now with entails contradicts neutral
we have the three labels that are
standardly used for nli data sets at
this point
look at some additional examples some
turtles walk contradicts no turtles move
i think that's straightforward
here's one that shows how intricate this
could get so the premise is james byron
dean refused to move without blue jeans
entails james dean didn't dance without
pants this highlights two aspects of the
problem first you might have to do some
complex named entity recognition on
james byron dean and james dean to
figure out that these are co-referring
expressions
and you also might encounter real
linguistic complexity in this case
emphasizing things involving how
negations interact with each other
this next example begins to show how
much common sense reasoning could could
be brought into the task so the premise
is mitsubishi's new vehicle sales in the
u.s fell 46 in june and the hypothesis
is mitsubishi sales rose 46
we would standardly say that that is in
the contradiction relation now again you
might pause and think it is certainly
possible even in our world that
mitsubishi could see a 46 rise and fall
in the same month so surely these should
be labeled neutral
but i think what you'll find in nli data
sets is that these are called
contradiction on the informal assumption
that the premise and hypothesis are
talking about the same event
and in that context we would say that
these are common sense contradictions
here's another example that highlights
how much pragmatics could be brought
into the problem the premise is acme
reported that its ceo resigned and the
hypothesis is that acme ceo resigned we
would probably say entailment there even
though in a strict logical sense the
premise does not entail the hypothesis
because of course the company could be
reporting things that are false but here
we kind of make an assumption that the
company is of an authority and will
likely report true things about facts
like this and therefore we allow that
this would be in the entailment relation
again not logical but much more like
common sense
so just to emphasize this here's kind of
the fundamental question that we
confront does the premise justify an
inference to the hypothesis
common sense reasoning rather than
strict logic
two other characteristics of this task
in the modern era are first there's a
focus on local inference steps that is
just one premise and one hypothesis
rather than long deductive chains
and the second is that the emphasis is
really on the variability of linguistic
expressions when people have created the
large benchmark tasks in this space they
have largely focused on just collecting
a lot of data
and not placed any special emphasis on
collecting examples that have a lot of
negations or quantifiers or something
that would really shine a spotlight on
linguistic and semantic complexity so
that's worth keeping in mind about how
we're thinking about the task
in the present day
if you would like additional
perspectives on this including some
disputes about exactly how to think
about the problem and what would be the
most productive i would encourage you to
check out these three papers by a lot of
stanford researchers
i think the fundamental outcome of this
is that we do want to focus on common
sense reasoning even though that's a
kind of amorphous and difficult to
define concept it's nonetheless arguably
the useful one for us when we think
about developing practical systems
now in a visionary paper that really set
the agenda for nli dawg and adolf 2006
they make a lot of connections between
nli and the broader landscape of nlu so
let me just read this opening statement
here it seems that major inferences as
needed by multiple applications can
indeed be cast in terms of textual
entailment
consequently we hypothesize that textual
entailment recognition is a suitable
generic task for evaluating and
comparing applied semantic inference
models eventually such efforts can
promote the development of entailment
recognition engines which may provide
useful generic modules across
applications
it's a wonderful vision and the spin we
might put on it in the present day is
that what we might hope from nli is that
since
since reasoning about entailment and
contradiction are truly fundamental to
our use of language that pre-training on
the nli task might give us
representations that are
useful in lots of different contexts
and document will actually continue by
showing that we can formulate a lot of
traditional tasks as nli tests and here
are just a few examples of that if our
task is paraphrase we might say that in
the nli context that means we want
equality or mutual entailment between
the text and the paraphrase that is
premise and hypothesis
for summarization we would do something
weaker we would hope just that the text
the original text entailed the summaries
allowing that the summary might be
weaker or more general
for information retrieval we kind of do
the reverse here we want to find
documents that entail the query
and then for question answering it's
kind of similar we could formulate that
as an entailment test by saying that
what we want is to find answers that
entail the question and the way we might
think about entailment for questions is
kind of illustrated here where we would
informally convert a question like who
left into someone left to give us a
statement and then we could say that
sandy left is an answer to who left in
the sense that it entails someone left
and i think there are many other tasks
that we could formulate in this way and
it does show you just how fundamental
entailment and contradiction are
to reasoning and language
and finally let me give you a sense for
the model landscape and how it has
changed nli is a pretty old problem in
the field and as a result we've seen a
wide spectrum of different approaches in
the earliest days you had a lot of
systems that were kind of focused on
logic and theorem proving i've
characterized those systems here as
offering really deep representations but
they weren't especially effective in the
sense that they worked only for the
domains and examples that the system
designers had been able to anticipate so
they're kind of brutal
uh following that you have a kind of
exploration of what what bill mccartney
called natural logic approaches bill was
one of the
early innovators in this space i think
he actually coined the term natural
language inference and he explored
natural logic which has some of the
aspects of logic and theorem proving but
it's kind of more open and easily
amenable to tackling a lot of data
and so those systems were consequently a
little less deep but also more effective
and a similar thing happened with the
semantic graphs which is providing
rich conceptual representations of the
underlying domain that we want to reason
about
another interesting thing here is that
you know
until recently
it was the case that clever hand-built
features which i'll show you some a bit
later in the in this screencast series
they were really in the lead and simple
engram variations you know traditional
models with hand-built features uh they
were the best models
there was a kind of faith early on in
the deep learning revolution that
eventually those models would prove to
be the best at this task but at the time
we just didn't have the data sets that
would support that would provide
evidence for that kind of claim
and so as a result for a while deep
learning systems really lagged behind
these more traditional approaches and i
would say that it was really in about
2017 that deep learning pulled ahead and
that's a result of modeling innovations
and also the arrival of some really
large benchmark data sets that would
allow us to train systems
that were effective for the task and
it's at that point you see that deep
learning kind of took over
and as a result in subsequent
screencasts we too will be focused on
deep learning architectures for the nli
problem